that's why one local couple has made it
their mission
to keep las vegas fed what started as a
social media conversation has now
brought happiness and comfort to
hundreds sasha loftis joining us now
live with the latest on this amazing
movement
sasha it definitely
is amazing denise and brian while the
kovid 19 pandemic as you said has left
so many of us scared
sick or worried about making ends meet
it's a lot to handle alone which is why
jim and julie danner are working so hard
to make sure no one is home hungry this
thanksgiving
they want two of those in here if you're
searching for what's good in the world
we don't judge we just love look no
further than jim
and julie danner we have five singles
they dedicate their days to
service gathering and distributing food
to create a sense of normalcy this
holiday season
everything's just been tossed upside
down you know
and a lot of the people that that
thought they had it all figured out
you know maybe not so much what started
as a small
facebook group has transformed to help
families
all over the valley through the covet 19
pandemic
those efforts have exploded ahead of
this week's holiday
for thanksgiving we decided that
we would do a big project and we would
put together all the things that you
would need for a full thanksgiving
dinner
together with volunteers friends and
neighbors
the danners have made 225 meal
deliveries
to feed over 800 people it's just such a
good feeling to know that
you know they did reach out they did get
what they needed
and now they can just relax and be home
and be happy well we're wrapping up a
year
that's brought so many sadness and
hardship
these two are proof there's plenty of
light
and love left to share don't be afraid
to reach out
don't be afraid to let people know that
you need help
because you are the champion
[Music]
the danners have already collected the
donations they need for thanksgiving
tomorrow but they are now looking ahead
to christmas
they're working on getting donations for
food and toys for children in need
if you'd like to learn how you can help
out we have links and information on our
website
8newsnow.com for now reporting live in
las vegas sasha loftis 8 news now